the protagonist of the film is a
mexican-american young man named jp one
day at a house party jp and his family
are engaging in cheerful conversations
his sister lily is busy making fortune
origami and passing it to everyone
suddenly the immigration police barge
into the house and restrain the entire
family jp and lily try to reach out to
each other when the screen goes blank
the following day all immigrant families
in america including jps go into a
frenzy because of the new law
implemented by governor finn harper a no
tolerance policy has been issued against
every single illegal immigrant and their
children even those who are born and
raised in america the illegal immigrants
will be imprisoned while their children
will be deported back to their own
countries until the next action is taken
they will be separated into groups and
kept in camps jp is separated from his
family and sent to live in an open space
with a bunch of strangers after two days
of living in the camp he finally sees
lily outside he tries to call her but
she is taken away on a bus meanwhile
several protests against the governor
are being organized by the supporters of
the democratic party a bill is proposed
to revert the latest law but it is
dismissed by parliament on the fourth
day jp and a select few are taken to an
immigration officer she suggests several
ways they can get their family back but
most of them include spending a lot of
money or hiring a lawyer the easiest way
out would be to take part in a community
service program the people who apply
will be taken to an old age home where
they will have to take care of the old
and sick retirees if they complete the
terms of service their families will be
let free and they can go back to their
normal lives the program is sketchy
starting the first step because only a
select few youngsters are provided the
opportunity but the desperate children
wanting to free their parents do not
think for a second before accepting to
go during the selection process jp makes
friends with a bunch of people first is
a black hispanic guy named big mac he is
a womanizer and doesn't really care
about the program second is camilla a
democrat protester then there is a
paranoid guy named chris who thinks they
will be drugged and killed in the
program and lastly they are joined by an
argentinian mysterious girl micah at the
old age home they meet the founder eric
dane he welcomes everyone in and thanks
them for being active youths in society
he gives them a brief speech about the
program being a learning experience for
many children they are then handed over
to the security officers cynthia and
james during their stay at the
establishment the officers will be their
babysitters they will decide who gets to
leave first and who doesn't the
participants are made to wear a tracker
on their feet that will locate them at
all times the process is again very
suspicious but the newbies do not think
much of it after that they are given a
tour of the place while walking through
the garden jp locks eyes with an older
woman named greta she looks at him
strangely without breaking eye contact
then they are brought to the lounge area
and left to entertain the guests they
can either talk to them read books to
them play chess and so on their main aim
is to make sure the guests do not wander
away because all of them have dementia
during the lunch break jp and his group
sit together to eat the taste of the
meatloaf is disgusting which breaks
their spirit even more since they have
to eat it for the time they work there
chris refuses to eat or drink anything
claiming that the government has mixed
something with their food he only uses
his inhaler throughout the meal while
the others eat then finally they get to
meet and socialize with the old people
everyone picks a guest while jp searches
the room for greta and then approaches
her she doesn't say anything and only
keeps staring at him jp takes this as a
hint and starts reading a book suddenly
greta loses control of her emotions and
tells jp that he will die here when she
doesn't show signs of stopping cynthia
sedates her and brings her away from the
rest jp is left shocked and guilty
assuming that he was the cause of the
breakdown an entire day passes in the
facility but chris still refuses to eat
the lack of nutrition causes him to turn
more paranoid than he already is he
thinks the window on the back of the
dining hall is one-sided and someone is
keeping an eye on them from the other
side the rest of the group doesn't
believe him so to prove himself he tries
to open the door as a result he is
sedated and dragged away to the
infirmary later that night jp wakes up
and goes to the toilet on his way he
comes across an owl that flies away on
seeing him seconds later he hears a
noise coming from the dark and sees a
naked old woman staring right at him she
yells virgil will set you free and
attacks jp he freezes in shock until the
security arrives and brings the woman
away they claim that she just ran away
from her room but jp can tell something
is seriously wrong with her the
following day work starts early the
security officer james calls jp racist
slurs which causes a slight argument
between the two as they are taking care
of an old man jp is attacked again he
falls unconscious and wakes up in the
afternoon to his surprise lily is also
in the room she reveals that she had
been with him all along and asks him to
just look harder suddenly jp wakes up
realizing that it was only a dream
however lily's comment stays in his head
for the entire day meanwhile chris has
still not returned since he was sedated
the last time when cynthia is asked she
reveals that he was sent back to the
detention center for not being obedient
after she leaves big mac bluntly claims
that she is lying he found chris's
inhaler in the hallways an hour ago
which means he is still in the facility
it is clear that the workers are hiding
something from them when it gets dark
big mac brings greta to her friend
phillips room he believes that spending
time together will be a good bonding
experience for two old people however as
he is setting up the tv something
happens to philip his bones start
cracking and he falls off the bed in
only seconds philip goes completely out
of control and acts like he is being
possessed his body folds into an
inverted position and he eventually dies
big mac is traumatized by what he had to
see but the cause of the death is
declared heart failure
that day eddie calls james and jp into
the front yard and introduces them to
his pet owl virgil this reminds jp of
the first night he was attacked but he
doesn't think much of it eddie believes
that jp can be a permanent employee
like james and wants him to stay close
although jp is not willing to be here
permanently he pretends to be interested
in front of eddie before leaving eddie
asks them to hog because he knows they
are not on good terms jp takes this
chance to steal the key to the tracker
on his feet he uses the key to unlock
the tracker at night at first he goes to
mac's room and finds him enjoying a
self-care day with face masks and music
mac refuses to come outside so jp moves
on to camilla's room she also unlocks
her tracker and goes to enjoy the night
of freedom on her own at last jp is left
with micah they steal alcohol and enjoy
it inside the pool jp is clearly
interested in micah and she takes the
hint they flirt for about an hour before
kissing and moving into her bedroom the
following morning jp wakes up to an old
lady beside him in the bed he freaks out
but is soon told that she climbed in the
bed randomly because of dementia later
jp is telling mac about last night but
halfway through the story discovers that
he doesn't remember what happened when
he got into bed as he is trying to
recall the incidents he sees greta
playing with a fortune-telling origami
this reminds him of his sister who used
to frequently make the same thing for
her cousins jp asks the lady if someone
gave it to her but gets no answer in
return suddenly she holds his hands and
starts shivering before the guards come
to his aid and sedate her jp and the
rest of the group are talking about the
incident when camilla reveals that she
doesn't remember anything from last
night as if she blacked out they also
discover a mark on her neck and
theorized that she was sedated when it
gets dark jp decides to search the
facility at first he goes to the
infirmary where only the security guards
are allowed to go he approaches greta
and sees a butterfly tattoo behind her
ears the tattoo is identical to the one
jp saw on his sister on the night their
house was raided it is now clear to him
that the old lady he was taken care of
is none other than his sister however
before he can take any action james
finds him and knocks him out the
following day the rest of the group is
suspicious of jp's disappearance they
decide to snoop around eddie's office to
see if they can find something micah and
mac go inside while camilla stays
outside to keep an eye on james after
searching around for a while mac finds
the blueprint of some sort of grinding
machine they are almost caught when
james comes into the room but he fails
to see them hiding in the corner
somewhere else jp wakes up in a
wheelchair beside two people his age but
when they turn around he is left
speechless one half of their face is old
and wrinkly while the other half is
young jp shortly finds out the same
thing has happened to him as well some
time later he is left alone in the room
but to escape he has to punch in a
password after giving it some thought jp
types virgil and unlocks the door i'm
kind of disappointed he didn't try
password 69 420 first at the same time
governor finn and eddie are at an outlet
of the chain restaurant liberty burgers
they co-own the entire chain and are
delighted by the profit they're making
recently amidst the conversation finn
inquires if anyone has made a complaint
about the burger patties in the past
month eddie confidently says that it is
impossible because he has found the
perfect alternative for ham i don't like
where this is going back at the facility
jp enters the production room and is in
utter shock to find dead bodies in
ziploc bags it is revealed that eddie
uses human meat and bones to create the
patties of the burger because real meat
is too expensive they use the bodies of
refugee immigrant youngsters to make
commercial meat the illegal immigrants
are given different hormones to
tenderize human meat and as a side
effect people turn old this gave the
business a perfect cover for what they
are actually doing down here jp freaks
out and bumps into micah while trying to
run away another shock hits him when
micah reveals that she was planted by
eddie to keep an eye on everyone from
the inside somewhere else mack enters
the vent to hide from the maniacs he has
also found out that they are being
drugged every day a while later he
reaches on top of camilla's room through
the vent and gives her a key to unlock
her tracker they go their separate ways
to help jp from different sides camilla
goes to the dining hall and finds out
that chris was right about the one-way
window chris was right about goddamn
everything however before she can tell
the others she is knocked out upon
waking up half of her face has also aged
jp is by her side telling her that they
don't have much time although they are
weak they decide to plan an attack at
night at first everyone including the
old people make sure that cynthia micah
and james are the only ones in the room
then they surround the three and proceed
to attack them jp tries to run outside
but while struggling against a guard his
urine bag is snatched away he endures
the pain and continues fighting
eventually mack and the rest of the old
people run outside while jp camilla and
lily end up in the production room there
they find chris who is still alive
suddenly eddie makes an attack blaming
jp for ruining everything since jp is
weak he is easily overpowered and put on
the platform to be turned into ground
mead but at the last second camilla
saves him after that chris's bones start
crackling he grows aggressive and
unstoppable because of the hormones in
an instant he snaps eddie's neck and
kills him as jp and the group walk away
eddie is ground into thin meat in the
last scene it is reported that finn has
fled the country and the entire burger
chain has been stopped jp's mother is
let free alongside all other immigrant
parents who finally get to see their
kids subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching